Danke, Herr Silberstein. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. November 2001.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 68 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
Herr Silberstein, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Bescheiden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich fühle mich seit ungefähr drei Wochen ziemlich krank.
Ich bin müde.
Ich bin erschöpft.
Ich habe wenig Appetit.
Ich habe auch Fieber.
Meistens abends bis 38,5 m.
Meistens abends.
Seit wann haben Sie das Fieber?
Ja, auch seit drei Wochen.
Seit drei Wochen.
Zuletzt das Fieber.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Feuerstein?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 3. Mai 1992.
1990.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
60 Kilogramm.
Herr Nosken, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. September 1964.
Herr Nosken, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 74 Kilo.
1,81 m.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 11.06.1969.
60.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Ich wiege zur Zeit 79 Kilo.
79 Kilo.
Frauche mit, oder?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Was will ich tun?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März 1954.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege noch 74 Kilo.
1,79 m.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März 1956.
Ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ich wiege nur noch 74 Kilo.
Ich habe abgenommen in den Design.
Und nachnahmes Boll B.O.Double L.
Herr Bohr, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege nur noch 74 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 44 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 25. März 1980.
1980.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege nur noch 79 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie?
32 Jahre. 32 Jahre. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
14. Mai 1992. Super.
Frau Heisann-Haut, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 m.
Wie viel regen Sie so seit?
60 kg.
Und der Familienname B.A. Umlaut, C.K.E.R.
Wie der Bäcker, der die Gurte macht.
Okay, danke. Frau Bicka, ja?
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Bicka?
Ich bin 58.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. August 1966.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie groß? Ich bin 1,73 m.
Noch mal bitte, 1 m.
1,73 m.
Wie viel regen Sie so seit?
Ja, so ungefähr 2,70 m.
Frau Hilingkötter. Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 11. März 1983.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Wie viel regen Sie?
68 kg.
Okay, schwarz.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. April 1967.
Okay, und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 77.
77, okay.
Wie viel regen Sie?
Ich bin 79 kg.
79 kg.
Wie heißen Sie Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Das ist Dr. Breitner.
Okay, Breitner mit E.
E-R am Ende.
Herr Schubert, was für Sie heute so?
Wie alt sind Sie?
38 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 25. Januar 1987.
Können Sie bitte weiter schpielen?
Am 25. Januar 1985.
Januar 1985.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 72.
Wie groß ist das jetzt wichtig?
Warum brauchen Sie meine Größe?
Ja.
Das ist eine Routemäse-Gefrage für das Gespräch.
Ach so.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,72 m.
Sie wollen sicherlich wissen, wie schwer ich bin?
Ja.